a brand new bungalow development is a
rare sight in economically challenged
southeastern Turkey
chatting yet a man and his mother are
moving into one of these houses soon but
they aren't looking forward to it they
have to move because a new dam is being
built and their old home in Hassan cave
Valley is going to disappear the locals
will have to relocate to new Hassan cave
which is higher up what's the use of a
new town if the cost is the destruction
of history and culture we've become
homeowners here but at the same time
we've lost our right son cave on the
Tigris River is located in an area with
some of humankind's oldest settlements
the valley has been inhabited since the
3rd century the Assyrians Romans and
seljuqs all left their mark historically
significant mosques and tombs have been
moved to an archeological park so far
Hasaan caves 3,000 inhabitants have made
a living from tourism new daily med
offers guided tours and sales brochures
but he says once the valley is flooded
he'll be out of a job
and there's no work for him in new hasan
cave even before moving in we had to pay
5,000 euros for repairs in the house at
the same time tourist numbers are
already declining there used to be 20
people selling brochures you know
there's just six left environmentalists
and archaeologists the world over have
spoken out in a bid to save Hasankeyf
and European financers withdrew from the
dam project to no avail
the police forcefully crushes local
protests like this year in July the
locals know that her son Kaif cannot be
saved but what does the future hold for
them politicians promise
all will be well once the project is
completed this will be Europe's largest
reservoir with new towns along its 170
kilometers in length and there will be
fishing and boat tours the tourists
don't seem too keen on returning to
Hassan cave to go fishing in a reservoir
I think that it is worked heritage is a
world culture and now electricity is
worth to the ruin and destroy world
heritage restaurant owner Buland Basilan
doubts that tourists will keep coming
instead of the cooling Tigris River Bank
his new shop is supposed to be here in
new Hassan cave but so far there is
neither electricity nor water and that's
not Berlin's only concern is how much
she just keeps Aguila chicken here we'll
start from scratch again we'll wait and
see if anyone comes and then we'll make
our final decision Chetan year that I
met would love to continue showing the
local limestone caves to visitors the
oldest ones are said to be 3000 years
old and served as tombs later they were
inhabited even up until the 1970s but
only a few caves will remain above the
water level
children wonders why this hasn't led to
more global outrage no to drop London
don't know how thank you fittingly
this doesn't belong to the people of
Hassan cave or turkey wealth of myriad
Iranian sunland you can G be that far it
belongs to all people after all this is
the cradle of humanity
along our Brioni but for now it's a new
housing development instead of limestone
caves for chatting you let him air
he's brought two saplings from the
valley and planted them in front of his
new house it might well be all he'll
have left from his old hometown once
Hassan cave disappears forever